you are looking sharp thank you very
much you look fantastic yourself thank
you a little roll action yes I do nice
and you're making it a date night I see
yes it's a very nice plus one I hope you
guys have a great evening and it's bound
to be a great evening because anola
homes 2 is in the house I mean the first
film was such a hit we had to get a
sequel but what do you think it is about
Enola homes why people are connecting
with it loving it so much it's it's fun
it feels good to watch the movie even
though there is a very real and very
important message which is within the
story the story itself is fun to watch
and a NoDa is enormous fun to watch and
that's easy to connect to yeah so as
Sherlock comes you like hopping into
that character I enjoy it a lot yeah
he's a great character and I cannot wait
I'm thinking the third one's on the
horizon only time will tell yeah but you
would be in for it right uh we'll see
yeah I'm gonna be quite busy so we'll
see and you are going to be quite busy
because finally we can say Superman is
Back yes indeed oh my gosh fans were rap
thing and they were going crazy what do
you envision what is your ideal future
for this character is it Man of Steel 2
is it a TV series what is it Henry right
now I I can't really talk about anything
what I do want is Hope optimism and joy
those three things are essential for the
character
you are the man to give it to us
let's see
[Music]